foreign
[Music]
I can do on the agendas and cancel
minutes of the last meeting which is the
5th of September
going through them Page by Page
starting on page four
five
six
seven
eight
nine
ten
[Music]
11.
Peter well yes can I ask um like you see
there I put a written notice of motion
uh there were a question I don't know if
we've had an answer but given the news
the last couple days
uh fairly important to get an answer
quickly
again
okay
there's a true record
Council finally second to White
passenger
all in favor please show
okay
who's against
on abstention
[Music]
three is the action list of pages 13 to
15.
Council homes
um
the dog and minor increase units in
Biddeford and it's been no teacher ever
so you've had they replied from NHS and
that they will have been replying in
full
um this is stage of the 30th of
September it's now the end of October
um I think my first race the matter
about three months ago so that would be
great for them write it down to remind
them I think it's not reasonable to wait
another month before every time well I
think we'd all be in agreement with that
question Hanson I think get not in
reasonable to expect just to write
another letter and ask for a swiflower
thank you
um
just especially Christy you mentioned
that so you can see the left a wall
sentence
information set out
so we can't expect some further
information in due course we could wait
to see exactly what happens I make sure
country requesting will be on our case
if a swift reply isn't uh before coming
happy with that yeah
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
going to Parker at the moment time
another seven minutes of lock all in
favor
again
on abstentions
[Music]
crucial
some people didn't put it at all
but again
all in favor of him please show
[Music]
okay item seven to consider
correspondence or other business
straightforward by the chair
I've only got one item you'll see over
the page
the staff Christmas Rocco goes to Hudson
is very kindly organizing the Christmas
rifle or the staff so any donations cash
bottles or whatever it is you wish to uh
donate before the end of September
please because yeah
so if any um donations do come in sooner
rather than later because it's unfair on
cancer holding out that little chasing
people I think she found it quite born
with us last year so I'll start the ball
rolling to the bottle here Claire thank
you very much
[Music]
okay item eight on the agenda uh to
answer questions submitted under
procedural rule A9 there was one
question and pensioner Brenton
you have the the answer in front of you
Professor Brenton uh you have a
supplementary question if you'd like to
ask him yes
um to be uh why not you know this was
this agreement with red Earth was under
the head of terms and I'm sold to them
well why why haven't we made our views
on that one
because there's a separate lease and the
payment is due to weather in April under
the least right
okay item nine on the agenda then
um petitions what petition has been
received from Save art historic village
of winkley from excessive Coast Building
this is on your agenda so you can see
what it is
um
unfortunately
so the petition was endorsed by 578
residents of winkley
the audition was scanned in and uploaded
to the relevant planning application or
file on the website in line with the
Cancer's Constitution scheme and as the
petition did not contain the required
number of signatures this is 2000 it
will not be debated at full Council
um
so leading alternate 10 Arkham
neighborhood plan
it was is it not now
shortly
yes
you want me to read it again
um You didn't hear it
I'll do it online again
which is petitions one petition has been
received from save our historic village
of winkley or an excessive and building
the petition was endorsed by 578
residents of wink
petition was scanned in and uploaded to
the relevant planning application on
file on the website along with the
council's Constitutional scheme and as
the petition did not contain the
required number of signatures which is
2000 or will not be debated about four
pounds
forward
just bear in mind what I've just said it
won't be debated but you're right but
it's like going forward don't mind not
either
[Music]
I don't understand having a minimal
number but I'm actually not being is it
important if it's why it's going forward
surely it's naughty girl that if there's
a contentious issue at Wednesday
comparing that with beta code is like
apples and bloody bananas and people are
getting numbers of people
a settlement may only have 500 people
sticking tennis and this could be really
crucial to that I don't know how they
meant again two thousand people were
signed so it needs to be looked me I'm
sorry at least working out because you
know I don't know anybody in
particularly with the other for the
chapter makes a cider no better but you
know
it's a fair point you might consider
forward and yeah I I've got a degree of
that but uh as the Constitution is
currently written two thousand is
required number correct but it can be
changed in the future it was at my point
experience suggests that when it is
foreign
okay so we need to go for show of hands
on that so
out of 10 Park of neighborhood plan area
designation for Pages 16 to 22. if you
see the report of the senior planning
policy officer
Sean is going to do that
thank you chair I don't propose to go
through the reports because in essence
we don't really have any choice other
than to approve the designation but in
in brief uh an application has been made
to us by parkham to designate as a
neighborhood area uh the ward members
and the community are very supportive of
that the proper process has been
followed and we commend that to you as
counselors foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
submission for Torrance pages 23-30 on
your agenda and I believe Christopher
only on his way
trying to be efficient for you tonight
champ
I was expecting that would last a tiny
bit longer um but uh I will try and
rather through
um in effect
the last time I spoke to your
um it was to address the subject of the
shared Prosperity plan a few weeks after
that one was submitted uh Deborah on a
Saturday morning without any
announcement whatsoever but onto their
website details the rule austerity plan
which they designated had been linked to
the shared Prosperity plan
but they didn't give us any open app to
make sure that actually they could
integrate neatly
um
um
um I think where it was very filled was
being supportive of uh two key strands
which was sporting rural businesses and
then rural communities and flex next
language
it is a purely Capital scheme
um and it must create additionality
um it's looking at kind of how we
actually improve something or let's be
improve uh opportunities for businesses
or improved lives for the rural
communities but it's looking to sell
next slide please
I think this is where as many people
experienced recently some of the
announcements that come out for
governments do not necessarily have the
full detail uh that we require the
briefing provided by Deborah was that
they would like to see uh 25 uh 75 cents
for it
because in their words it takes a while
to develop a capture project
but then they were open to that split
being adapted by uh local authorities as
the requirements within their locality
um depending on how they foresaw that
money being utilized for Maximum Impact
next slide please
necessarily too much that uh spread
there but in fact in similar way to
leave the scheme when many of you will
experience a bit of it is included but
for example uh they were advisable is
not
and it's like this
so again this is how this links between
the share Prosperity plan trying to make
sure that after we're working in a
similar Direction here there's no full
overlap was given between uh
schemes but again it's very similar to
that sense of the the former leader and
program that was uh rolled out by North
10 plus very successfully and which
allowed to know the businesses in the
area and to kind of amateur supported by
another Community projects
um
the key issue with this is the fact that
uh when Deborah announced the scheme
they informed us that at four percent of
the revenue supports that have been
allocated to the share Prosperity fund
should double up
to support local authorities with the
rural Prosperity plan so effectively we
went from four percent
um over one million to basically in each
team having two percent per attuning uh
it works exciting to know that pretty
much every local Authority in the
country then push back on that uh and we
were informed by Deborah that they were
looking at the situation to see what
could be done and unfortunately added
yet
and with the the last month or so with
the changing the central government we
haven't had about it
the next slide please
uh I had to correct one thing on that
slide uh in that uh North End Council
would then have to push their uh
approval back to the 23rd of November
um but apart from that what we're now
looking at is moving on from uh this
full Council session today and then
developing uh the high-end addendum that
we've provided
that is not providing the good detail of
exactly how that money will be spent for
example the full detail of the leader
scheme for the simple facts that we have
not been provided by default with the
precise in and out of exactly what they
would like to uh
within those teasers so that would have
to be worked out and play the next
couple minutes
next slide please
um so working with North Denver council
with one of two very clear
streams and where we feel that this
money will have most impact and also
being aware and realistic that other TDC
capacity commitments and making sure
that we're being able to deliver
next slide please
so uh the first one and you were very
much encouraged by Deborah to make sure
that as much of the money as possible
rewards getting out to businesses and
communities within those Rural and their
characters
but at the same time ask about one of
the earliest lines making sure that
those businesses and the community who
are being supported to become more
environmentally sustainable through that
that this should have a real green
impact
at the moment everyone comes Enterprise
to as all of the businesses are
desperately looking for that kind of
capital investment that can then support
them so for example lower energy costs
and make those revenues able to come
down to support their business we're
looking forward
next slide please
and then the other strands that was
identified was about how we've now
utilize uh the rural Prosperity funds to
make the Maximum Impact to real
communities
um looking at those core pieces of
infrastructure that otherwise
unfortunately do not have an easy way to
buy them
but there are not significant funding
streams out there for example uh we know
that we've committed to replace strategy
how do we actually lose our boards with
that larger investment and equally great
time to Penny Market is a significant uh
use of infrastructure that means a lot
of property Titan but also to the
central
um Town economy from that location
so it's sort of uh it was considered
that this would be a strong way of
reading that board
next language
at the same time
where conversation uh
Apple was not just around making sure
we're getting that leaders in Broad
communities and for visitors but also
how that could be utilized to support
some of those industries that mean a lot
to communities and places with Leisure
facilities and cultural facilities
having repeatedly signature challenged
over the last couple of years and
especially with increasing energy bills
and so it's highlighted that they'll
bring an opportunity to support those
with capital instructions and move
towards uh doing this solution
alongside and an ad mentioned that
Victoria Park and break science
which brings me on chair to
recommendations
thank you Chris
I'm sure there will be quite a few
questions
[Music]
but secondly I'd like to move to
recommendations for us I think officers
proposed often a really good balance of
funding across the whole District which
research reaches both the rural farming
areas and also into the town going
through the leaders both done and also
the chosen Capital project it would
reached a wide range of Ages building
our communities and boosting all over
the economy it would help for any sense
of Pride back into the places where we
live I really hope that this will be
successful and that's a much needed
external funding from central government
and finally come to fruition here in
Norwich so you may have a second
oh and seconded by cancer alignment yeah
[Music]
[Music]
um with regards to the two
infrastructure projects in Victoria Park
I have absolutely no no issue with at
all and one can see how reject the pla
the play area there being being renewed
will
um assist with the Regeneration I have
concerns about the detail of the plan or
the the
um the vision or the
um pannier Market in great Torrington
um is actually this just complying or us
putting a building that we own
fixing it because it's not in good
repair but I don't see where the
Regeneration is going to come from from
those of you who may not know Torrington
a great Torrington Padia Market is in
fact it almost entirely occupied by by
shops uh small shop units either side
all the way through which are let on a
commercial basis it it's not an open
space market area which one would
imagine would then lead to Greater
regeneration I I want to I'd like to see
greater detail as to nearly 200 000
pounds in this day and age is a lot of
money and by the time inflation has had
it had a bite at it it'll be nearly
quarter of a million pounds by the time
that the money is spent
um and I'm not sure where the
Regeneration is coming from or is it
actually just Torrington fixing a
building but I I can't see whether
there's going to be any greater benefit
for the local community by doing so
because
the space is occupied by by the people
who are renting shops there's an escape
to do anything much more
[Music]
um
I suppose
in one way you're right it's it's it's
porridge doing repairs
but if we don't use this fund to do it
we'll be using and it won't be done
directly ourselves we've obviously we'd
then be taking money away from some
other scheme which we would like to see
you talk on yes I I completely agree
with you about the risk of just kind of
like the like
um I think there's also an important
psychological elements behind this it's
about Community Pride and it's about uh
investment in those places that feel
left behind
and I think uh all of us can relate to
that sense of seeing physical decline
and trying to arrest that but I think
that you're right we should be looking
to try and progress for example uh area
accessibility and make sure that this
really is
not just putting it back to how it is
but how it's improving it as well
surely but they have some value added
from it a great Torrington needs some
value added from it like for like I
don't think is is an acceptable
situation
uh about President Christie Frost and
then Council James and I'll come back
before
thank you um I've got three queries
really
um I do welcome the money to Victoria
Park
um but how much are we sure from what we
need because I seem to remember a figure
quite a lot higher in this 150 000 and
I'll ask him because both the Town
Council and the British trust have got
money in their budgets the war Victoria
Park so how much are we short
so uh I think
there's a couple of different levels on
that sort of uh question one I think
that there's been certain lack of
clarity in terms of actually how much
had been assigned by whether British
trust and uh the Town Council
specifically to Victoria Park
um
I know that Adrian Adrian has also gone
back and requested uh similar to
councilor that Newton was alluding to
you have an initial bigger uh from the
land and then it's making sure that that
figure is still then relevant
um but I believe I've been sure to
probably correct me that at that time of
speaking the numbers then added up to
that first phase uh Works being
delivered through this
um the second question is
um what I raise when this came out some
time ago in our recommendation it's a
bit buddy about the cost of managing
this and it does say there that uh
requests further costing beta to
understand the Mandarin cost because I
think we this is where Devon County
we're going to basically take half the
money right there some fund I've always
I'm always very interested in how much
we're paying for this management so I'd
like to see those figures as soon as
they're available
and this is uh where
one of the things I mentioned was around
the past not overextending ourselves in
terms of capacity uh in terms of this
fund and making sure that we're actually
keeping that as straightforward as
possible with the community
infrastructure and delivering that will
be done by existing storage
teams and therefore that wouldn't need a
management
going out we also know that for example
uh North 10 plus have significant
experience of delivering those neither
summer schemes and so like approaching
it like that will be able to
significantly reduce the the build-up
preparation that can then come with
those additional costs look forward to
the figures
so third question um
councilor Newton's already touched on it
uh the panda Market in Torrington
um
theory of benefit of course town
councils have taken over
the market it doesn't cost porridge
anything
and I I really would like Torrington
Town Council to look at taking this over
because we've spent quite a lot of money
on torrent companion Market over the
last decade and I'd like to know just
how much because there does seem to be a
lot of money going towards it I can
understand you know we've been given
this sort of windfall why not spend it
there but I'd like to just look at those
figures because I do share Council
Newton's uh concerns over it his future
especially thank you
thank you James first and then that's
going to be forward thank you
leadership last week we discussed it
very fully I think I upset one or two
when I queried the figures because what
concerns me is how much is left for the
rest of the district
um you know there's a lot of them to go
into small business internet and privacy
which has lots in the Royal area and
apologies first of all to declare I am a
director of law Kevin loveston if I
could have done that first so obviously
I will be careful on the phone with him
but I
on both of them you could argue you know
you could argue from a very rural area
one would
money in Victoria Park going to the area
and the same retirement I would hope
that Torrington will mean there will be
more likely and it will maintain the
building and like cancer Christie said I
would look forward to once it's in good
condition we do talk about whether it
should come under the Town Council
rather than the district council they're
putting 200 000 I think that's something
they need to be discussed so
I am pretty supportive of it I've been
involved in the discussion from the
staff
I have reservations but it's funny
that's coming to us we can do jobs that
we can't afford to ourselves and I just
want to make sure and taking
um
uh your point uh by Simon sign up again
it won't go to 250 because I'm
determined that the rest of the money is
the best of the money you know those uh
sorry person you would
um that there isn't you know 200
thousands of past Champion running you
know and Invasion or not that is the
money that goes to it and as I said I'm
100 although I'm involved in North Devon
but those of you in rural areas and
always when it's not on the list that
people coming forward and support small
schemes that would qualify for the other
money thank you chair
and Country Country Ford yeah thanks
Jack yeah
um
basically picking on the point that
potentially firstly made
um
well I kept you always get the ground
down on Pro actually about a community
but you're quite funny he's unless I
even wear a nice meeting tomorrow you
know Community safety partnership we're
all meant to work actually internally
with those organizations and it's
alluded to the fact that I forget
[Music]
if you don't like it well
I apologize but we should be talking to
people who knowing that the pound's good
track or obtain council's got money
available you know
mobile phone anybody heard of that yeah
let's talk about it I've realistic or
say that added value
well I'm just playing we could always
say about that who knows what the added
value is going to be anyway that's it
that's a picture of statement
we've got
and there it is
survivors don't want to see the line
because I was like you know I'll get
over it but it's actually not funny and
the fact this has come from another
source you absolutely like leader every
time we we debate a pain never mind 195
code you should have scrutiny but
sometimes we're crap out but actually
this needs to go forward and it does
but I didn't value it's a number you
know probably more that will only ever
come apparent in the future
and then I think the country Lord
thank you Chad
I find it quite interesting Council of
Cole haven't even said that this would
benefit the whole District in the rural
areas and things like that and cuts the
James has already said also he isn't
going to see a share of this I expect
the councilors in Bradley in the similar
sort of areas of looking at this going
which doesn't happen very often
um I know we have got the grants
the other part of the money for the
grants meetings to come out and I said
we must make sure that money is ring
defense and the the play area and
Victoria Park doesn't gradually improach
on that and eat the rest of that
but for whole city no I am disappointed
that it's not on the list there is
I suppose the difference is that there
are less obvious things that we can put
the money towards and holds me as
councilman Newton said it just seems
like oh Torrington Bay Market is there
it needs the work this is this wind Hall
as councilor Christie said and and we're
trying to take advantage of that and
there are projects that holds me which
are capital projects which could be
explored
um it just seems disappointing that
they're not and I I do think that this
isn't going to the two schemes which are
being put in place are going to leave
behind
um other parts of the district again
yeah
what's going on with it so I maybe said
it first but it means the start but it's
this term we were talking about
no um torrington's
here then and the guy in the uh and I
open my behavior
and I look at uh I look at
um
I see that absolute joy for the children
my whole history you know it's time now
the Judgment do these two things I'm
sure there will be money left over and
there'll be other things that you know
let's just address these two and do it
with Goodwill for the children for the
people of time let's put I mean let's
let's look forward to the Apple let's
get it done
okay
now it was councilor Pennington I think
I believe everyone
thank you it's just a question
[Music]
or is it call me I just wondered which
one it was
Chad's comment she told me thank you
thank you
I'm pleased to hear that I made the
statement I'm learning
foreign
[Music]
25 000 people 65 million people
multiplied by a thousand this is a
million pounds worth of investment
that is two percent of our deficit
is it going to happen Chris can you tell
me because I think we are wasting my
time
I I hope so
I can feel your pain
having been through a few rounds
recently but we just need to be we need
to be in it to win it is a great hope we
have nothing
well we certainly got some deep thinkers
here on some things
um I think it was potentially bright
next then Coach the boy told bookley
County Brampton
thank you sir um uh yeah it comes the
Lord was correct uh actually important
notion that we look at the restoring
while hotels was it two years ago but um
as well as Victoria Park so it's a
scheme of both of them it's being that
we wanted to do before we just haven't
found the money so here's an option on
the table ready to go thanks anyway
we've turned it away
um also just forwarded maybe give it a
bit more insight for the position of the
building so the actual Pro upstairs is
structurally questionable and the the
museum that are not allowed to fully
utilize it because they don't know how
safe it really is
um and also there's the front of the
time that's awful which you know isn't
that being attractive to tourists so
there will be small you know um benefits
uh but by doing it is by doing them with
generation it doesn't it's not very
clear this is an industrial strategy
kind of you know you can see it's clear
economic benefit there will be economic
management
[Music]
will help them along
um
um Victoria Park I mean yes it is really
good but people go from across all of
Northern them into it you know I mean
sure it's you know it's not that homes
worthy but a lot of people do still
travel to it from all over I don't think
we should just you know too quickly
thank you
bye Council would last
um
I wondered how how these sites were
decided like you have a list do you pick
them around him is it that they've been
on the list for longer than other things
like how do you actually choose
um and then it was just with regards to
um the vehicles as well so you know
saying that the planning Market you've
got potentially structurally unsaved
reading is this quote realistic like is
it is it based on quotes or it might
have I'm just I'm just curious in the
process early
understandably
um
yes
um main Market was based on quotes from
uh this age team
um episode 10 of 10 that they had had
um cancer Newton uh been expected as we
did to them uh at I think we had about
10 000 uh on at that point because
realistically but it's by the time this
gets around to next April
we need to be aware that there are those
significant cost increases
um but this at least provides us women
go back to those uh
contractors and actually make sure that
we cancel over on the budget that we've
got
um
where sort of the process was was I was
asked by confessity a series of options
through to the to leadership That Was
Then debated and discussed and looked to
actually what projects or states of
Readiness as well to be delivered
um
will again come back to as a capacity
and we still need to be planning for
success for example we have to have been
Maritime Innovation Center we have the
environment Center
what we couldn't do is then start
looking to develop additional projects
that would leave us potentially unable
to deliver on the expanding commitments
um so it's making sources of that
balance uh and impact availability was
there
um
councilor Brenton you're an accident
thank you chair well we're all familiar
with the saying oh we have divided Rule
and we've heard it tonight in this
debate don't we say [ __ ] uh Atari
internet games weekly and all was really
included Westward oh why why do we get
so excited about this it has been
dreamed up what two prime ministers ago
which Checker is it is this gonna be on
the table they're just stubborn uh Boris
Johnson's uh
Britannia part two 250 million slice
that away you know and if we get any of
this money I would love to be proved
wrong on this you know pointing the
finger up and say you've got that wrong
Brenton you know because we got the
money is it going to come through I do
feel so sorry for the opposite they're
going to spend time doing a list just
have a shredder at the side of you
because you know you don't have to walk
too much but I hope I wrong I really
hope I'm wrong as well to be honest with
you they would make on so much and
they're slightly away so much and local
governments have stopped it underbellies
a lot and and because we're going to
take a wrap where it will come next
spring we have to put on the counteract
the sure that we will happen because to
make the shortfall of everything else
we're not going to get and and I you
know it just it's bearing in a way hey
all right that's the life we live in at
the moment thank you Council Brandon
um
yeah I just like to know how you
apportion that some of the money because
in reality 150 000 pounds before
Victoria but is literally just two new
breeds of the play equipment which
doesn't do very much on the wide scheme
of things so I don't know how you came
to the split
um so the across the standpoint was uh
trying to establish a
commitment in language support and
councilor Jones uh so in Casper James
but actually we wanted
at least half of this to being done on
an open eligibility bidding in process
some of its businesses and communities
as their access those uh that was
part of the Democracy in terms of
business and
we then
add a number of conversations
[Music]
when
the Victorian Park figure came from is
Adrian Avery and my team does have those
proposals uh from a tender rounds to
have some contractor ready to deliver
facility against making sure that we
have a sufficient quantity in that to be
able to uh to deliver
um but the realistic thing is that we
would love to have a lot more money to
do a lot more with it
there's a lot of need across the
district
that although this is a very pleasing
wind pool it is a company
[Music]
let's die cancer early first and then
it's uh hopefully perhaps happen within
the last week on this
sorry forgot that is
so I just thank the council dependency
for bringing Health into this debate and
the market house has been ill for some
time and this is a windfall so I think
we should use it to bring it back to
Hell
the answer Benson's a good points there
but um
I'll leave that for another day
causes problems in the past and you well
know thank you thank you thank you
um a few more bits but um
more than two years ago and we agreed to
look at it
um it's a two-star listed building and
as the owners we've spoken about it
before we've got a legal obligation to
keep up to standards and as the local
planning Authority I think it's
councilor Hicks who brought this up a
past meeting we should be setting an
example as the local planning authority
to everyone else in the district
um there's already Planning Commission
approved on it it's ready to go it's
everyone's agreed on it as a plan
committee and that has unanimous support
um it's got full support from the local
community
we've had a letter from the town
councils and Steve and the leader and
I've just now boarded it to everybody to
have a look at
um that last minute
um and also the museum
um are fully supportive of it so really
support them and they're doing really
great things
um at the moment and you should go and
have a look
um
we've had public contributions in the
past so we haven't tonight because we
know all about what it what it means and
how much it means great parents and
there's rotting Windows paintballing off
the Bell coats have been removed because
otherwise it was just going to fall down
and possibly injuring some Sunday
um please let's get this restored with
former glory in the center of great for
instance these this is external funding
why don't if you turn this down it would
just be it would be terrible as a
council would be quite embarrassing
thank you much Chris
you are passionate what you do I've got
to say with our numerous talks and I do
wish you best letter what you do because
you get back around all over the place
but you still keep going I really Marlo
but you I'm in full support of this we
needed to contribute our own building
School Board
the future councils that come in it's
one of our properties of storage and
unfortunately we've got quite a few
properties in disrepair they've only
been left this week if you've not spent
any money on them to upgrade them no
it's coming around against Bitters and
they ask because now he's got those
money but thankfully this is a gift
force in the most so I'm in full
supporters going forward okay it's
Chris's idea back to Town Council lovely
if your town can actually financially
support this we've had issues a lot of
times a bit of a Time Council not all
accounts that support the pending Market
some do some don't if this is the fee
you're gonna have going forward but
definitely a full sport is you can't
live to get uh give you can't look at
gift balls like this whatever not accept
it you know it's me going for it's great
Victoria Park I'd like to see more money
going into that of course it would be
one of all members but Chris you didn't
know the question about their finances
from bridge trust or the Town campus and
what they've put into the pot you must
do because
there were
slight discrepancies between some of the
figures that we have been informed
previously about where a figure was
directed to Victoria Park or where a
bigger multiple plate facilities across
people
so that had been said um a certainly
happened since those attackers or hands
to British assembly yeah I think I think
the answer there was the ward money set
aside for macro played with some was
specifically for Victoria Park and other
the other remainder of that those bodies
were other areas within the bit of other
things
right I think we've giveness
um
[Music]
construction culture do we get a chance
of processes
you mean a project we've just been
discussing the remainder of the money
and those details will be worked out um
with uh see the management team and uh
presumably with it plus in terms of what
the application process will be and what
the criteria for that page
so they will report that their change
so we need to develop some scheme
guidance against which we'll measure
applications it wouldn't be sensible for
us to be reporting every application
into some will be low level some would
be five thousand pounds but it you know
I I think it's probably sensible that
within any guidance criteria we have an
upper amount of a reasonable sum that it
comes for consideration to cancer so we
can feed that and factor that into the
scheme guidance if men respond to detail
thank you so I mean obviously as lead
member I'm interested in agree with
environmental projects particularly
along it's just the second Point
um bearing in mind that concerns that
some accountances that really expressed
about times of the market would it be
better if we need to set the glad to
vote
um
[Music]
those homes
right
have you got a second
so who was considered Conor Morgan's
second number
has been seconded so all three shows
there's an amendment
well I just asked a question and
apparently the first the question
did that limit came afterwards and
hasn't been set with it okay
foreign
[Music]
Market from the Metroid bar which is in
the report okay items
[Music]
I'll catchers beautiful
Clarity are we separating the bid or are
we separating Something That We're
voting off
it'll be the big will be separated the
amount of money that's allocated there
was two separate schemes numbers
correct
[Music]
information
thank you
okay
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
withdrawal other countries
you know they are one you either remove
you can either vote you can have a
proposal remove one from the agenda
in its entirety so we don't we don't
vote on it
I mean if we split it you're still going
to be voting on it that is the proposal
as a as a group or you do them
individually
that's not the opportunity
Market I think that's irrelevant so yeah
all right
um
[Music]
it's only withdrawing was I yeah okay
right it's been proposed that we accept
the report as population consecuted by
Professor Langford
show fans all in favor please say about
our three parts of the recommendation
yeah
against
um
thank you
um
thank you very much
thank you
Department
right okay item 12 on your agenda is uh
in court marriage councils and temporary
importance of Parish Council Pages
31-35 it says to receive the report of
kind of legal in government but being
polished
this should be a lot two minutes
Council will do enough for it therefore
unable to function
um legislation allows the principal of
warranty to make a little bit of the
point the district councilor onto that
Parish Council however this one unsure
Parish Council need one councilor to
make them caller I've spoken to the
chairman there and so has Council Rock
and he's informed us that there are a
number of people waiting to be co-opted
onto the parish council therefore we're
looking to make a recommendation that we
appoint Council lock onto them out of
this one parent Council to make them
core at which will allow courtship to
take place I've I've moved
pretty sure
well apparently I didn't read out that
this was a temporary appointment for
temporary it is
anonymous
[Music]
13 a schedule of committee meetings
committee report
s to be a very quick report
and the recommendation is to improve
those yeah
should I appoint this
Professor Junior
Jacob in a month says could we ask that
um future uh or continue to have future
full Council and plans meetings held
here at kadstown and not down at the
Town Hall this be this being a more
business-like environment and also in
the ongoing situation it is healthier
because we can spread ourselves out
where necessary as opposed to the rather
sort of sentimental view of the time
opinion
um
members at leadership have asked us to
invest many in the town hall to upgrade
the ieg and electricity electric
facilities to enable us to move back to
the term for
um so uh Tom and the team are going away
so and that would be way too many
continuous anticipated
Quest is also cost associated with
continuing to use this building security
and so forth and obviously the example
being our main Civic building
okay
a number of hand shopping
and Shop that we're not sure exactly
which order but I'll take out a lot of
personal impact yeah as what is the book
gaps of Newton's idea that
um until next April they'll all walk out
to what plans can be to meet in our help
here all right the argument has been
um that we might sort of another book
intake in place and therefore do lose
Revenue but on the other hand we are not
paying the heat the town hall or
electric and I can think of no worse
place audio is better believe in Town
Council than the worst place to hold a
big committee meeting so I would like to
see you and Paul Council plans continue
here until change the council
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
that
um
that may be something for a different
meeting but all we're voting on now is
the schedule of the week
[Music]
now decision-making body
but
[Music]
and committee we're always decided
I'm totally confident that meetings
worldly behind in the devil
am I correct
there's been numerous discussions from
different different members of over here
either insured or shouldn't be held
um and many members felt that they want
to go back to the terminal I've seen in
many members want to stay here uh so
there's there's no definitive but as
much we are meeting or we've been hurt
and as you said earlier this is about
the schedule you want to meet in dates
rather than any venues
were
we get very few members of the public
out there that is one thing that does
concern it we talk about local democracy
and we need I really appreciate the fact
that we've got people that come in into
the town hall and actually take part in
a living
[Music]
you think right
we've got the uh
schedule a meeting is what we're going
on yeah who was a proposal Council
Manley seconded by professional Clark
all in favor please show
unanimous thank you
active travel to receive a variable
update in terms of hey I did say that
you can have five minutes
lesson we use brief as you can because
you can see the meeting is going on and
on yeah
[Music]
um thank you counselors yeah
um just thought it would be a good
opportunity at some point to say what's
been happening with the active travel
agenda
um because it's been going for two years
now
um on 27th of July 220 councils voted
and now and have unanimously to approve
my motion proposing what a council works
with other local authorities and
Community groups to encourage safe
cycling and to identify and promote
civil cycle routes resulting from this
an active Travel Group with sports
chaired by me and facilitated by storage
officer Adrian Avery poor members our
councilors Christie laws Cottle humping
hacker games myself and County councils
regular attendant also part of a grouper
is a representative from northern Devon
cycling campaign the county highways
officer Matthew Collins and Vanessa
Saunders the town clerk at holsworthy
gone assembly The Joint climate officer
occasionally attends as does Christopher
and TBC in the group invites other
people when advice and further
information is sought for example in
suspense the national cycle group and
also the county put parts officer Martin
Academy the group has worked primarily
to identify a suitable cycle and walking
routes in our area and with discussion
as well of our opportunities for horse
riders one of the major routes we've
identified is the west of hole through
to Northern to Biddeford and the King
using quarterly groups creating
dedicated tax and utilizing existing
roofed cycle walking routes alongside
Hayward Road the objective is to
continue the Rhythm from the key to
length with the long bridge and the
target crane either along the dedicated
psychopath on Barnstaple Road the part
of which is part of the Brunswick walk
development or in front of that
development along the river we wish that
the link should be completed by a safer
access to the Parker Trail through
ettering Brown close recently sounding
so the residents that produce broad
support for this proposals the benefits
of the linkage to the trail of the
Strategic Westward homes a Biddeford
route would be poorly enormous and
converting healthy Leisure cycling
contributing to the tourist economy and
helping those who wish to commute my
time to their places of employment we've
also identified and improved and
improved route alongside Mateo way to
live with Easter water in the Tarka
Trail and also a route extending the
existing cycle walking Track at Poly
Fields east of the water to join the
trail at the far end of Torrington Road
we've also discussed routes from West
Middleford and also in Torrington
the group is also welcome positive
um positive news about the exciting Ruby
Way project which is now well Advanced
via the whole story
The downsides being obtaining to
Progressive again with Barry Roots
linking Biddeford with Westwood higher
along the Old Railway line
uh Mrs Pages would have been a wonderful
opportunity for local people and
visitors
um making a safe alternative travel
route which would also serve the new
housing developments here with open Home
despite section 106 and only being
allocated to it and it being in the
County Council infrastructure plans the
project has been held up by due to Young
Wilderness that two landowners to allow
the route through their land
uh we have made great efforts to
investigate ways of achieving this
project and this hope that we've helped
from our County councilors the hurdles
can be overcome
more positively really there um the
truth welcome last year the suggestion
for the currency but a so-called local
cycling and walking infrastructure plan
or else you wet for short be produced
with answer a bit of the Northern areas
boarding the basis for attracting
funding this was a great opportunity and
led to this Council North Devon District
Council and some parish and town
councils such as Northern and Trinity
and funding to the project which has
been run by an experienced transport
consultant wsp
steering groups met regularly and as
attended by Council and officer reps
participating councils including myself
and Adrian Avery The Roots identified by
the active Travel Group have been worked
up by the Consultants into detailed
proposed cycle walking routes and these
have recently been subject to the public
consultation which produced response to
over 300 people and so to final overall
plan will be ready early in the 224 and
be part of what I've been forming the
basis to attract and follow them and
also the aim is the adopted routes to be
part of the local with ice local plan
including apart from the main work of
identified an imperative alternative
routes to groups looked at cycle parking
opportunities we've drawn up a list of
priority sites we're also looking at
encouraging the cheap bike to skiing for
people on low incomes investigating a
local bike safety scheme for children
and we supported and proposed local
scheme promoted by co-cars which would
enable public use of the pool of
electric cars and electric bikes which
will be serviced by a network of
charging points including I thank all
those on the group that I work over the
last two years and also age in agree
with these constant help and support
there's this home mental network of
alternative travel routes can be
achieved which will contribute to a
reduction of car use therefore resulting
in our conversions and to save the
healthy amuse and travel thank you any
questions
[Music]
Mckenzie was president today as well we
were in agreement to support is Matthew
Collins uh produce the document today to
us so but is the LC whip that we're in
need of quickly to obtain obviously the
major funding but today you know we went
through hard talking with full support
myself included thank you very much
that's what I do
Britain
I go back to a type of choices
meeting we had virtually win
John Hart leadership
and a number of counselors
I'm not meeting including yourself as
names
said that these roots would include
horses
Elsie whips include horses that's the
national policy active Travel section
six all rooms should include horses
they should all belong to use the
funding criteria includes all the red
line substance saying that these routes
should be included
why oh why for these roots not include
horses when you yourself scheduled
support
the question is there is no reason why
they cannot
you have excluded the path of the
vegetables inside even a submitted the
consultation responsibility and also
most certainly you have the Strategic
off-road
advisor for cycling UK and Kieran Foster
say most clearly he knew that is your
best method of obtaining funding for
these groups to get them built would be
to include all Newtons so you did not
have any objection
from yesterday
with disadvantage and required active
travel agent and the conformant to look
at it again so you have gone back upon
your insurance
to the councils that you need to do
equestrians
I understand
you'd like to answer that
yeah
you're gonna have to email Matthew
Collins today because Matt Collins is
obviously a different opinion to
yourself in a group is no horses but the
way you have to email directly to get
the answer that you earn those accounts
itself because what we're telling today
is they didn't really feel the mix of a
horse and any example that's architrary
was being very prudent in City Safety of
users there I'm not trying to argue with
you you're passionate what you're doing
but you need to email Matthew Collins
simply give you a direct answer to that
I come back to you
the Tarka Trail does not get the use of
that the camel Trail does which is the
most used trail in Britain and that is
multi-used
Penang trails are multi-used yeah
the conservative Minister Richard
bennion MP in a ministerial statement of
over a decade ago said that these roots
should be multi-used but it's
conservative party policy there is no
evidence of conflict on these rooms it
is
specified by
governments they want them more to use
they are funding protein Trail soft
Brands who have most of these Trails
have received money for a new barriers
and the parts of everyone
they have removed these barriers to
allow all user groups where is your
evidence well there is no evidence I
think this is clearly beyond the Beyond
agreement of what we can determine so I
think the advice from Council model is
to speak to the down County Council
directly on it because they're they're
not being done yeah and Karen UK has
spoken
so I had to just say that I've I've
spoken to you and technically all
concerns on board and I I didn't notice
and put your attention towards
um part of the report that we're going
with the LC work consultation that horse
um the matter of horse riding will be
taken full of consideration when you put
in your point your points I understand
and I've also mentioned that in my
responses and I've moved ones have as
well and I'm fully the hope that all of
this will be taken on board in a
detailed are working out of those sort
of responding of the consultation so I'm
hoping that your back is organ I should
also say that my understanding is that
there are some of the county has got a
rule
um we're also I can walk members writing
projects I don't know whether a customer
is that where where horse riding would
also be taken on board well we'll be
discussing anyway
s of motion but we've got one number to
motion from cancer Brendan
thank you I think
uh well uh chair I think it's so much I
think has been said on the tent really
um you know there's a lot of buildings
in our area that are upon security and
et cetera Etc with the rising hospital
and fuel it will look into improve the
insulation and the thermal efficiency of
their homes but these bits are kept
they're not very expensive they've only
been 15 pounds but the thing is that
people have especially living to keep an
eye on the end of the monies you know
the 50 pound for a little item that
you're never going to use again after
you use the one to check where your heat
links are Etc
um would not consider buying one of that
so you just let one out to our residents
and they can use it and bring it back in
give them some idea how to prioritize
their installation I'm going to do that
or indeed whether they're protected any
serious leakage from
thank you
counselor
yeah
bicycle it was sort of like they opened
out some friends and I was wondering
about practicality so they've really
um I think it means sort of a discussion
with with officers
some sort of seeing which will help
people identify
um energy leakages so I just wonder
where the council Branson but do you
think it's really realistic or else is a
counsel to do it or should be working
through in some other way with or local
groups
sorry for your channel thank you well if
there's any help I do have a paramilit
mentioned um
camera that you can if an infrared one
if they want to use that they're more
than welcome the council don't have one
as far as I'm aware just one brief
question
um
what would happen if there if we've ever
was given the seek protection found that
there were some cold spot in the law who
would they then be applying to to get
funding to do their Loft insulation
which is it themselves and they wouldn't
be expecting targets
number
yeah
what the person you do to identify where
the problems are it doesn't matter that
it's up to the individual when they pay
for a property or private grants or
whatever because you're complicated
system though by return of installations
but that's that's not the issue thank
you councilman
[Music]
[Music]
I think it should go to an energy
company such as prefix one energy
um it's the perfect project for them it
would be totally suitable sit with them
and again that they would be able to
help residents
um then find funding to support these
families
I think it would sit better with them
than us and seconded and your hands and
support please
yes very briefly customer yeah I don't
really mind how it's delivered I think
the reason why I said about TDC there we
do have a an office down at Riverbank
convenience doing it that way I'm going
to want to do brilliant work but I
wanted to do people generally know where
they are
um it may need to be signed posted from
us good but we should let them know that
this uh is this is available to them
that's the point I'm trying to make the
highlighted thing is the fact that they
can get some help in finding out where
their homes are leaving
you've kind of check out you've got a
number of Imogen cameras um
I'll be quite I don't see that there's
going to be a big take at all because
I'd be in support of purchasing one if
they're around the cost that you're
talking right and it can be loaned out
on an individual basis you know it's
yeah I'll just point out this could be
an interesting I just went on Amazon
cheapest or best one on Amazon
678 pounds
right there's people being seconded pill
finds in support of potential friends
and
thank you
guys
[Music]
keep your hands up so we can get the
numbers
[Music]
okay some extensions
housing provision and printable Land
review receive an update from the leader
of the people campus
I was just gonna say that um I think the
climate emergency working group has got
a small sort of funding I think there's
like
yeah
because that would be separates
well get together and have a channel
later at some point
okay
item 16 leader and the chief executive
to report on it
uh thanks chair so just briefly your
wrote You've Got a nature with this
shaded in part one and part two of your
agenda and members of the public uh
listen we'll assume the same and the
reason we've got it in part one and part
two is because there's uh quite a bit of
sensitive information that members of
full-time talk uh I pledge in the facts
of the mechanism is that that will be
discussed in part two of the private
part of the agenda that is anticipated
that should some states Anderson land
from that review come forward we will go
back into part one uh so remember to The
Republic will be made aware of any
society
division in the future
foreign
okay those members of the public that
are here man I'm afraid
there is some comfortable chairs
downstairs I believe